yeah man what are these drugs freedom
[ __ ] is that those what it is is
honestly oh yeah Brendon and Brian are
dumb right right so so they're
technically dumb right so so what'd they
do with that entail if you're dumb
so what this is what they do is a guy
yes
some guy just anyone let's say we'll be
like hey there's a new thing right let's
say ingest it right and it's good for
your health
and so they go nah never mind man who
cares now let's see no exactly
let's do a little improv I'll be the guy
you be you okay I'll be okay this is
what normally okay I'm just some guy
there's a new thing and it's out then
you should ingest it oh no thanks
go [ __ ] yourself okay all right yeah
right that's how it goes when right now
now I'll do Brian okay hey man what's up
yeah yeah I'm good man are you just are
you no yeah no I'm just some guy I am
some guy because I don't think I've ever
seen you before
no you wouldn't have dumped some guy
there's a new thing you should get it
and you should ingest it give me all of
it okay
can you talk about it on your pod
hundred produces and I hope it makes you
do well yeah and makes you money yeah
and I will be your test subject
okay that's a gross now four months
later I have psoriasis so [ __ ] lovely
when he says when the guy says hey have
that and wash it down with that get
psoriasis yeah oversimplification is it
we're so loud that we're getting banged
like what's that means feel oh yeah it
is do your father still know who Theo is
I've never met Leon feel 1va ugh that's
how you separate the OVA and you bastard
via Vaughn we've got Theo Maddy here
dude I'm sorry I'm nasally guys you guys
I'm really nasally why I got stuffed up
because dude I'm [ __ ] nasally by I
went to the doctor the other day and I
go like this what is it he's like dude
sometimes you're just [ __ ] too sick
with it that's not what doctors I was
like I'm sorry and he was like yeah he
looked at me up from his glasses and
goes like this there's really nothing I
could prescribe you I said but you're
the doctor he said I know but there's
nothing we can do
you're just too sick with it he said
you're too sick with it and I'm like
that's why I'm nasally and he says
that's my best guess too sick with it so
tell you i DD T yeah or D I don't even
know but he just goes you're sick with
it man you are sick with it and then I
go out and I go to pay and I was like
what do I owe and they were like you
know what we don't want to charge you we
love your work but you're come on tell
come on please right I know I was in
your shoes right here I was like please
let me pay something you know at least
two three grand I don't know how much it
cost but they were like whatever doesn't
make a but she was like she was like
yeah you're sick with it and I was like
oh it's all good she's like I knew
somebody who was sick with it once I was
like who and she said a Gregory Peck I
was like Jesus that was a long time ago
but apparently you know he was very
famous more your time period but that's
there's no like The Grapes of Wrath
which was big right around when Brian
was 40 all right but but congratulatory
is very funny Sam congratulatory because
my podcast congratulations is just
skyrocketing in the charts man you've
been talking about yourself the whole
time no need to start talking about
other things besides yourself not people
you know what's funny I'm not talking
about myself but I think I I swear to
God there was a second a few months ago
I started thinking of I started thinking
that my name was what the [ __ ] it's him
you're insufferable no no this is other
people I know what's going on dude I've
been around you yeah you get recognized
okay but don't act like you're not
Justin beep no no that's what I say to
them I'm like guys it's not Justin
Bieber and they go like what the [ __ ]
it's I thought my name for it for a
second I sort of got it now my name was
what the [ __ ] there he is no no and I
was like what my name is Chris yeah and
they're like yeah we know yeah and you
know I've seen a lot of pictures of you
sometimes that on the internet when
you're young
mmm when you didn't have a beard and
when you had short hair mm-hmm and it
was interesting because like that's the
guy with the lunch pail right
what well wait what well some people go
through a transition and what they do is
they go there's the guy you shove in the
corner okay
aim your lunch whatever it is right or
or let's just shove them around or or
you know what that's what they do right
yeah no and then then go don't get up
then you get mad in the mirror and you
I'm gonna change that's true and then
you go any of your dad's like let's get
them a stylist whenever and then he got
the Chagos grow your hair long grow a
scruff and then reinvent yourself cuz
your name used to be Dennis
now it's Chris is that true no that's
not true my new who's never Dennis it
could have been back then right all
right no it was not it couldn't have
been my name is Chris and only Chris
wait a minute if it would have made a
deaf and also people [ __ ] if anything
my name is what the [ __ ] it's him and
that's what I'm saying now when you're
at your holiday what you post videos of
your you and your your home your dad can
barely barely take you and your brother
like I said the most ridiculous cop
that's true we do we have ridiculous
conversations but you know what
he made us so it's his fault I know it's
not you guys are close though yeah we
were very close cuz mom good how's that
good how's your brother who looks up to
me no that's not actually he's skinny I
could beat his ass okay dude but why are
you saying
when I see him I go but punch you in the
chest once you'd quit but why would you
say that to him but why would you say
that I just want him to know that I can
kick his ass all right dude yeah I like
I can kick his ass and by the way if
he's walking around with his girl I'll
take her if I want bro okay you don't
know who's a that I wouldn't oh well all
right
I got to my go hey scram
all right that's some 1960s [ __ ] and
I know what you say scream to my brother
one time no no no that's disrespectful
dude
grando and then and then you you go nah
bro yeah you know Brian don't you try to
you you try to
peacock up and bro I go what know what
I'm too lazy for you to deal with bro
I'm too lanky for you to deal with you
want you want to stab huh you want to
stab brought me that's absolutely not
how it will go down you want these
[ __ ] spaghetti arms wrapped around
your [ __ ] neck dude you in the mood
for some dying in huh you in the mood
for some [ __ ] dalian food that you
say when you [ __ ] up I got like that I
look at people dead [ __ ] square in
the eye and I say hey dude
are you hungry cuz I got some dyin food
for you four years and then I [ __ ]
whip around they don't even know they're
like where'd you go and I'm behind them
just strangling the [ __ ] out of really
strangle I don't even choke I strike
okay last time you thought you were in a
fight oh god dude so many times we have
you and your brother ever come to
fisticuffs only one time
really yeah hold we young launched him
you did yeah cuz he was choking me or he
punched me or something
I don't remember younger brother - yeah
and you you beat him up he was punching
me or something then I let him have it
but I was bigger and older so no dude
don't be it was probably about some cool
[ __ ] like money or checks boy Joe Gerson
yeah your ball or your boy because you
looked human to me they create cereals
pushing the sky but everybody maybe you
could put this is a third guess in a row
he's brought this up but I yeah I want
to say of course you know
can you put cereal and milk in him or or
did you mean it's a boy instead of coal
oh you know I want to actually FaceTime
him later and see if there's any any
lucky charms on him hey me oh you're
being so disrespectful in this podcast
and we haven't even [ __ ] gotten okay
into the joel is my now my friend joel
revolution MMA yeah I went to I went to
I want to get to he's a great guy and is
my friend now
no not hold on he's my friend first he's
your friend he's I granted you an
audience with him now here's what I'm
getting at what bothers me what what is
that you took a couple of classes with
him at his at his school and now you're
asking Brendan where you can train here
I need say something before we get okay
you said it before we get into how
you're gonna train I want you to know
something and I mean this so seriously
and so sincerely I'm gonna say thank you
I took a nap a Rip Van Winkle nap for
five years I woke up with my hair way
too long my nails way too long and my
[ __ ] beard way hydrated and that's
the main question behind okay let me up
after my Rip Van Winkle Matt you've been
training
I mean training yeah I mean so can your
shirt in your shorts and your undies
every single [ __ ] day right
you still being them would be you don't
last one round bro you understand me my
nails out I can't make a fist I be he
did do Jiu Jitsu for pleasure no no
Chris did I know he did for six years
and I want to say this [ __ ] you
what [ __ ] your [ __ ] oh wow Jiu Jitsu
okay if you know step to me when you're
ready soon as that that's not mine dude
I turn my [ __ ] off yours brother
dude don't mind I don't like how you say
bro after that and that's your phone you
know why because you're [ __ ] terrible
with your phone no cuz I keep things
quiet right well although he's Jenkins
text now hey Chris hey setup dobro thank
you man we're because I was I was
breakable
well how does it you set him up and on
me because you know why dude what setup
do you get really Wayne yeah yeah butts
and also you know what it is dude it's
about like raw talent a I don't think II
think you have that listen you're not
malleable you know you're headstrong see
thank you for bringing this up yes I got
a way better way to do it unbreakable
boom in your face oh yeah I mean
unbreakable huh what are you gonna train
you're gonna train Mme
in case you gotta what put your hands on
somebody What's Up [ __ ] don't
get too jumpy on shoulder the mic away
what's up if you feel froggy leap I'm
ready that's all what Mowgli from jululu
well that's what Mowgli means frog so
why don't you be a little Mowgli and
[ __ ] leap into the jaws of this snake
dude I don't like the wrap you up I
don't like the animal references man
don't shush me bro that's [ __ ] weird
that's weird weird
you get a weird man Chris what when all
of a sudden did you started to get
healthy nowhere I get these texts brah I
gotta try to come the house yeah I know
after you you don't have a bad body at
all you know I got I do squash it likes
a terrible no they're not that's okay
because I'm 37 and I just feel like you
know I'm gonna break down in the next
eight years if I don't it feels that
when doing theaters and stuff for real
just work right up there
is that what well yeah I mean I'm just
wanna get fat I mean well I mean I don't
think I really run that risk yet maybe
like when I'm like 55 the one good thing
about you is that you are very [ __ ]
consistent and disciplined yeah for an
for a guy who you wouldn't think you if
you decide to it you will show up every
day that I like that I would never think
I was like I like it
yeah when I first met you I thought you
had horrible drug addiction yeah and you
were super undisciplined yeah turns out
you don't drink you don't get drugs
you're super disciplined all you have
the attention span of a small points it
okay you never have I understand you
never far sorry I fell asleep no III
totally seem like that and I understand
that and I even kind of emote that but I
am so disciplined yeah it's like why is
that where's that come from your dad's
very much that way he is yeah um I don't
know man III Italian work ethic I don't
know I want to be I want to be good and
something and like I also there's not
many things I like and when I find
something I do like I wanted I want to
and I don't look at it like you know I
want to be better than other guys I'm
not competitive at all like in that way
I just want to be good for me I would I
good you know like when I did jujitsu I
did it for six years and I got to the
point where like guys were like going to
be doing tournaments and wanting to
[ __ ] and I was like yeah it's rabbit
hole yeah it's my hobby you know and and
with stand-up I turned my my might what
I love into my career and that's amazing
for me because but then like so I don't
have a hobby you know really your
brother said that you as long as he can
remember you've lived for one thing yeah
and that is to make people laugh yeah
you just that was your Emma always man
even in high school I know always to be
a silly Sprint's at the gym let me tell
you something I am the I am the biggest
[ __ ] at the gym I am working out so
hard I'm drenched and nobody else's know
you your dress you drenched doing what
Sprint's j-rok you have a trainer ass
you don't know how to do anything I do
dude I had a trainer and now I know how
to do it so I [ __ ] you know alright
and I go [ __ ] sprints like I do do
what you do when was the last time you
worked out well yes
you know I did yesterday what you know
what I did yesterday what'd you do this
is how much of a [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] I am to do on Labor Day I
was like a [ __ ] coffee shop yeah
and I [ __ ] ran home I did in here in
my [ __ ] outfit dude
I ran home how far was it what was like
too hot okay
ran home now when you say in there don't
you mean you plotted no I ran dude my
jogged okay job you plotted no I John
you look when you were running it was
this hot as a story where were your
wrists pinned at your ribs and were you
looking up with your chest arch no dude
that's how you I was down and I was
going like this I know it was hard to
people kept stopping in cars and me like
you're hilarious well no I think what
you were doing is you were you had your
arms because you're not athletic
I'm very fo not an athlete well I'm very
athletic so you you you arch your back
like a Chiquita banana
[Laughter]
yeah a [ __ ] disrespect you let that
one go on your own pie I'm gonna let
that one go now I don't let that you
came up real close to my face I'm gonna
let that go and I'm gonna describe
alright bro guide your wrist pin and
[ __ ] off smacked you do it one more
[ __ ] time
and then what I'm coming at you you run
with your body and you have your wrist
dude
yeah you can't get by it'll jump somehow
I'm spindly dude how are you
so spindly I know you can my new shirt
your new shirt
you're Cassius Clay new shirt you a
[ __ ] fighter that's so disrespectful
that you smack my face a bunch of times
I could literally see you for a salt
well I will make a [ __ ] and
and this has been a terrible podcast go
to [ __ ] you that's right now I've been
the [ __ ] just use don't ever wrap me
with your knuckles I had the best I had
the best podcast here thanks guys we did
it and speaking of congrats thank you
very much all right I have a podcast
congratulations now I want to let you
guys know my [ __ ] I'm not trying to put
my [ __ ]
now my [ __ ] is rising it is rising and
this podcast is good and you know what I
stopped making a podcast because they're
not in the podcast business I have a
cult and it's a cult
you look like the guy who killed
everyone in wake up Chris you can't just
admit I would never kill anybody but my
goal is to get this podcast going so
much so that I have followers and then
we go to a log cabin and we chill out
and we sit down for the rest of your
life and we learn and we talk about
commodity share ideas and I appoint
people elders and I don't know if you've
been looking online hang this up yeah I
want to bring this up but talk about a
nice thing you guys are two elders like
with this well I mean a little bit but
once we get to the logjam and it's gonna
be great this all makes so much sense
Brandon don't put a look at me all right
that's what they do they make you feel
important that you are important right
you are important I'm not it you're very
important thank you and you're important
to me in your important to all of us
thank you if you're a member of my
occult and also you know the podcast and
you guys are subscribing yeah you're
another
yeah you guys support what we support
the cause
sorry [ __ ] go look at his eyes look at
that already don't look at the funny guy
don't look at the picture though because
he who so I know I know he's hypnotic as
[ __ ] so charming Oh Brandon look at me
just stay with me it's okay with me yeah
yeah let's say I signed it for you to
get a pal they shouldn't let it be known
the pendant job and Bryan Callen I I
don't say that no and you are hold on is
about the certificate eldership says let
it be known that Bryan Callen and
Brendan Schaub have demonstrated an
exceptional commitment to living and
spreading baby ship in the world and
honoring the congratulations show with
the consumer with the consent of daddy
parentheses crystally a pet this person
henceforth carries the status of elder
we simply have to free and he signed it
dude this is legit you are you are a
very dangerous person nice right it's a
good no thank you but kind of thanking
you are we the first elders crazy like
12 else's elder some really really
people who some people who really really
people who really spread the word and
help but like who though so what do we
spread the word Chris what is your cult
stand for what do we what do we say
about your cretinism okay let me explain
what that is hedonism is the pursuit of
pleasure okay so in other words it's the
pursue the apathetic pleasures like sex
or min and Brendon that's not a good
example I live my life like that yeah
but he's not your daddy
no but in the bottle now dude you have a
lot of it we're gonna wear white linen
it's gonna be crazy I love white
charisma I'm really into fashion and do
we're cool shoes oh yeah yes yes and we
talk about you there's girls
oh there's girls there in there
beautiful and they aim to please and
honestly there's like there also if you
got if you like guys to that's that's in
no listen it will be Brendon Brendon his
neck is getting all weak Brendan tighten
your mouth tighten your mouth come back
over here I know what the pin actually
looks really good on you look Han I feel
good Brendan he's [ __ ] charming as
[ __ ] he's got tremendous charisma
that's what cult leaders do are though a
threesome man yes sir
oh man listen Chris it's working look at
his [ __ ] eyes don't look at the
picture don't look in his eyes for real
can I have your girl no you can have
them all no that's what they do
my shoes and clothes fact he's trying to
take everything for you and my alright
it's an RS 7 but yeah don't get all yeah
yeah that seems a dolphin - all right
listen bro I'm so hard right now I'm not
gonna look in your eyes but I'm so hard
that guy you're welcome friend put those
up and you know what I'll frame in the
spot yeah yeah yeah well add it to the
dick diver picture nice okay Chris Chris
um I know that you're 90 you're about
85% serious about your cult so yeah and
so I don't approve yo you know what dude
you know what you are dude no I'm not
he wants to go I'm now you can have one
if you join mine no we all have it I'm
not joining your dude sorry there's so
much fun around here there's a lot of
shitty [ __ ] there's a candles we don't
use there's some letters on the ground
ten like chin [ __ ] a cleaning service
signs on the ground this place this
place dead bird down there yeah this
place is not remember last time let the
hangover it looks like like yeah I was
in no you weren't you weren't in it yeah
I was three guys were you I do that
because I have flames right here that
can so that's what's up so I go we've
had literally never spoken about that
terrible no it's not terrible [ __ ]
amazing okay but why did you go did you
wake up and you were like okay I'm just
a coffee and I'm tired of that I'm gonna
get flames on my hand you got a key now
you there's nothing about you nothing
that would that would signify flame are
you [ __ ] out of your mind dude what
about you know what you're not your dude
I'm on that's right that's why I did I'm
on fire don't do that okay but that is
like a terrible 80s Ryan no not and
there's nothing about you that sweetie
there's nothing there you are basically
low energy all that old [ __ ] your human
broccoli that's I'm not kidding no it's
mine to be that way but you you're for
you you're pale I'm good like you need a
nap all the time
nah bro I'm killing it what are you
doing on the phone no no don't do that
yeah dude don't do that don't snap snap
[ __ ] don't stop no way dude
Taryn introduce you so it doesn't catch
fire because I don't want [ __ ] fire
to catch see it's my garden you're
putting water I'm gonna get water on
this side I'm gonna go [ __ ] stop it
it's not to get water on that side
they're not hot
I am [ __ ] no why did you get but why
did you say let me see that
okay it's so annoying Chris fire man on
fire like my last special - you don't
get it it has layers do not on your
[ __ ] no no my podcast rips my podcast
raffish dude what does that mean it rips
what do you mean it ribs you know when
you're going on a roller coaster and
it's like that's when you turn on my
podcast
that's what's HAP and then and then once
it starts dude you're [ __ ] you're got
you oh and then you start going down
[Music]
[ __ ] bar on right it's just you huh
it's just you what you say about bar the
bar put that [ __ ] bar on put that
bitch-ass bar on so you don't fall out
while your list
okay so say you I've had people fall my
guess is is is four is what people
should listen to and they're working out
yeah well no well if I mean it's very
dangerous because I've had people I in
their fall out of their car listening on
the freeway yeah it's I believe that
you're lying they fall they fall out of
you can't recognize when you're driving
down this oh dude you know what the
[ __ ] most hilarious [ __ ] was dude I
was at Starbucks and coffee bean today
because I got two coffees for me because
last time I got two coffees and I gave
one to you and your [ __ ] sweet tart
tart Nass wouldn't drink it you know
these terms sweetheart NASA might go but
do my shows people go you got a sweet
tooth oh don't point things that people
probably America's then I got a deal
with me going yeah I'm a sweet tart
Tyrell dude
young guys are like you got a sweet tart
or as they drive by I don't like it well
don't be [ __ ] sweet tart tart nothing
sweet tart tart about me at all I'm a
[ __ ] hard older dude
yeah I've seen a lot of [ __ ] dude I [ __ ]
it tight you know what's so hilarious I
was at [ __ ] Starbucks getting my
second coffee today yeah and the guy
goes like this I came in today without
laughing he goes Chris you are not a
household name so don't act like the
[ __ ] guy at Starbucks laughed and he
played it good he was like what and I go
like this I go like this I looked at I'm
gonna go like this
Chris yeah people actually I have family
members who go what's that guy crystally
delial I know they do so your name is
not because they have a listening
problem and not during problem what's
that guy Chris D'Elia like dude and then
what some people go they don't do that I
just heard famous they don't do that
dude also I want you to take that hat
off that you send pictures of us in oh
yeah anytime about my my Johnny Depp hat
yeah yeah be a giant
powerhouse don't know respect him saying
no in your face like thanks I like that
a lot I think there's a lonely
incinerator somewhere and I think that
it needs that hat and I agree you throw
that away it's fine you're an artist
okay we are our day to get our an artist
I'll never say it again but here's the
deal
if you can tell someone's that artist
from here yeah yeah yeah kill them
yeah kill them if I had Johnny Depp in
there right now he begged if you're not
Johnny Depp bro you know you're too big
to that always the same shoes now you're
those guys need to get a different
wardrobe period don't worry who they
I don't care if you're I don't care how
many awards you want I don't care how
good yard acting don't wear all that
goddamn jewelry ring boy does that bring
up Jared Leto jewelry no guards good so
you in the tundra bye
I agree don't wear a scarf when it's
breezy
agree agree he's a beautiful Jared
Leto's beautiful he can't even rest up
like the Joker it looked like it was
just Tuesday for him bye-bye yeah yeah
no he's a beautiful man and talented his
[ __ ] but he almost gets oh no that's the
wrong argument the argument is don't
wear that write him what the [ __ ] is
what's wrong with a nice hat he's
knowing the 15 he's Goldman more has
beautiful gangsters a beautiful dowry
about Capone he wears hats a beautiful
you don't live 600 pounds for reps
you're a bull giant bull Giants are not
allowed to wear dainty had quite a long
argument we get out Capone what you make
fun Al Capone well your notes out Capone
well is Al Capone yeah that face the
other went one of the other gangsters
where he'll drive your metro and
artistic in kind of Moluccan areas it's
tilted to the side
you guys are arguing about this all
wrong so what's our you make Kris don't
wear it period why there's no this guy
that guy you wear a ball cap or you wear
no hat and maybe you wear a [ __ ] ski
out if it's cold out I agree
[ __ ] oh wait [ __ ] no keep going what's
wrong with your tongue what's wrong with
that that's actually do yours what's
wrong with that that's oh that hurts too
much that's a costume
you know what he's dressed like a funky
aunt yes
see ya he's dressed like the [ __ ]
annoying single aunt that comes over
that is so true
Amen what are you wearing yes so true
you look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I
agree with that I'm not rocking that
ridiculous out there it's fine I get it
he's talented as [ __ ] he's handsome as
[ __ ] I get it he's rich
he figured out our he's Irish Ange it
he's not rich anymore but every level
Jared Leto's killing it Jared Leto
actually looks good no he doesn't wear
scarves on weird [ __ ]
yeah he it's just deep you know what the
thing is where the works on him but your
thing is you guys know no fashion
I know fashion bro you pale altra busan
I thought oh pants freak cuts a free
concert at a crystal e-comm I do like
your shirts on my pocket I do like your
shirts okay thank you I got the me
undies on you guys know about me on the
me on D family hey bro listen Jack you
don't think me on these called us first
and was like what do you think Chris I'm
a horrible fashion you know what they
called you you think his dick will fit
in our boxers oh thanks oh hey bro you
guys know maybe if you wrapped it around
is trouble I swear to God I woke up the
other day I didn't realize it there's a
Starbucks in my guest room there's a
star but how did you not know wait a
minute I don't know it so they started
like someone paid the franchise fee and
have you know what I guess so this was
yesterday isn't she three employees
other customers yeah because you don't
go around if you have a busier house he
said it's obviously very big how you
know what okay so MUC see okay so that's
a Manor is that a manor or is it a
mansion
don't look like you don't know the
answer to that have you seen your being
how about this what you don't I'll let
you know
oh come on you're the first of all
you're never gonna get back to us with
that
of all you [ __ ] don't mean it I'll
look at your hands you're forgetting
crooked mouth that's not even a thing
you do that is so not a thing you do you
don't do that modest right now he's
making a wide face
what's [ __ ] do you have a name for your
house is it or is just an address
probably just a house you know it's got
it what well its got like a CD on the
gate okay what what is it you're so
expressive when you're lying you'd be on
the game no you don't have that look you
gonna be careful you're gonna flatline
again you're gonna die if you know dude
I'm fine dude right now cuz I feel
really good does your place how are you
gonna [ __ ] Hey lived too hard he lived
too much you do you have that that
blonde draft coffee that new Starbucks
they have that yeah it's actually one of
those Starbucks what it I don't know
what they call them but I was trying to
ask the employee buff so it's hard it's
going to bed and cuz it's a 24 do they
work for you - that's a [ __ ] manager
stays I know I should be making some
sort of money right yeah do they you
know what they might close but I don't
know dude your studies have the new like
the new chicken tortilla egg sous-vide
do that yeah not just the other two yeah
bacon in Gruyere yes they say they had
the but they're always out oh [ __ ]
they're always cool too because if I
don't have a if I don't have a phone
charger they have those [ __ ] table
chargers yeah
I can just go on and just place my phone
on there so you had to know that when
you went in there you're like put a
Starbucks here and then this now do you
allow anybody in the Starbucks or is
there a they they yeah I mean yeah you
can let anybody in mostly I would say
it's it's mostly white people and okay
just wipe he was just mostly white and
who else that's a bonus
I'm not trying to I'm not trying to is
it are you saying that you have a white
only Starbucks I don't care I'm not
judging you all right I know and again
it has nothing to do with me it's in
your home Chris no but in your house
you've been saying that yeah that's five
minute I didn't I didn't I didn't have I
didn't know yeah we got it we gotta talk
about your three about a guy who's got
it I mean I've got a big house no no no
no no I don't have any do you do admit
that they did there is a Starbucks in my
home that's a conference I found out
about that yesterday about what that
it's is it is that why people only are
there by coincidence or is there a
barrier to entry to people who have more
melanin in their skin so I popped in
about five or six times just because I I
still every time I was like wait a
minute really and I would walk in and
I'd be like you're home yeah okay my
home yeah and every time I walk in maybe
six seven eight nine times so yeah there
were it was pretty much white people
okay only that okay so they're a sign or
enjoyed Starbucks so they do have signs
yeah but they have that sign that says
Starbucks and then they have a sign that
says things on this premises may cause
cancer and birth defects or whatever
that and then oh we can write we have
the right to refuse service to anyone
and how much of anything there was there
was small wording under that do you know
what that said under the weir is that we
reserved a right to refuse service to
anyone and then a bunch of stuff under
that that was in parentheses did it say
of color it said something like because
when I got closer to the Sun yeah this
was small right yeah yeah but they were
like it said no black oh boy super
you have white school lesions and you
have to change and that's it that's a
that's a bet that's a dream I have
nothing to do you bring this to any
court in the land land will say you had
it in your house sir right right here's
your house where's me judge I didn't
know that no no but you do now and
here's the thing you judge you've known
for a day that you have a whites-only
room in your house it's not a room into
Starbucks and I think I start buck to be
in a lot of trouble
let's call it Starbucks it doesn't
matter if it's a rumor as far as walking
chin walks in with a friend of his who
happens to also be Asian or let's say of
Latin descent or what can what happened
let's put it this way I'll stop right
there chin doesn't walk in they have a I
don't mean III again yesterday I walk in
I'm noticing all this [ __ ] yeah
and they actually have a separate
entrance I was like oh my how annoyed
you know Chris what happens when I walk
out and I'm like they already stopped
you when you walked in no no it's your
house but nobody stopped me
well you look Albanian which is
technically white so there you have it
so yeah so I walked into the part you
know you know the you know when you walk
into a bank and they have the first
entrance and then you have to wait for
them to have the light turned green till
we open up the second entrance yeah okay
so sort of so what happens is know when
when a bank gets robbed if a bank is
robbed there's two entrances right and
there one after another and the robber
leaves the one door and then they trap
them in the little area yeah to where
they can't leave the second door
right
yeah okay yeah this Starbucks has a
version of that right so what that would
be a red light coffee I mean that's from
the whites-only star that's a racist
coffee with that ring so it has two
names right so it has it's called the
simply strawberry okay and then and then
so they said so and and then and then
under it it says made by made with real
strawberry sugar fructose whatever sorry
it's a little red we wish that it was
everyone but sued this is [ __ ] up this
is not gonna look good saying that cup
one day no wrong in two rows just let
them in yeah and as you wake up one day
you walk into a room yeah you're out you
haven't been down that corridor or
whatever sometimes I had you open up the
door no no that doesn't happen ed
corridor the you see all of a sudden a
bunch of green and it's a Starbucks near
like holy [ __ ] I had nothing to do with
this
okay that's where I'm coming from right
it happens to be I
apparently I'm realizing now a white
zone now we're realizing that Chris
you've known for a full day and you
still haven't taken action have you
talked to anybody about like in some
ways so I asked the guy who works there
right and I was like what's what's his
name so his name yeah his name is uh his
his name is Henry yeah yeah it's a
regular name right yeah and so so I
asked him how did what's the deal with
this right and he goes like this I don't
have anything to do with it no for this
insanely racist coffee shop Henry's a
white guy who did the put the sign I
mean not that it matters but yeah I
think Henry might have something to do
with white guy okay but then you but
you're also gone
everybody's like anybody there took
responsibility for their insanely race
you said there were three people yes
three other guy - other who with you
other guy yeah Henry
Zack that's right Henry yeah white god
I'm not even gonna ask it well Henry had
Cody Cody yes those guys are white those
are white Kody's young okay yes he's
probably as those parents were like yeah
let's call them exact konjac Brian
which watch this well call him a
throwback name yeah yeah my
transatlantic guy and then Cody and sag
yes and Zack and Zack is an older man
okay he doesn't wear the the green the
apron or whatever okay so he's the man
what is he yeah sure he's a medicine
what's he wearing so he's got all sorts
of other [ __ ] going on he
he might be the one no I don't you know
what I'm not sure because he's not even
wearing a Starbucks outfit what is he
wearing that's what we're saying so he
has like this why oh go on
[ __ ] go white top is it a white just
a-wasting exactly yeah yeah smog is it
to keep off the red and black oh wait is
it a verb boy hold on
is it a robe yeah I mean maybe he just
wanted a better he's a he's a grand
wizard tastes magical does he have
little symbols like on his would neck be
next to like oh you're and this is the
Auto Club and then there's like an
emblem you never read in black [ __ ] like
those symbol symbol so the [ __ ] Klan
secretly open the Starbucks in Starbucks
and they're profiting and you have the
Klan in your house you have your
probably probably can gasp him out of
there I was like gasps about yes there's
a guy in the guy who can he shoots a gas
not gonna kill him but it'll it's a
noxious gas that will get if they have
that in the entryway it's an anti-racism
between the two entrance an anti-racist
gas they have the gas you've got to get
a guy in there okay let me tell you - I
was like what this is illegal and they
go like this dude don't worry about it
and I'm like okay it's just weird you
open a Starbucks and I got so I drove it
here it gave me a Ferrari they gave you
a Ferrari they're probably making that
much money there you got rich clap do
you have like a lot of like probably a
lot of just like white girls going in
there cuz they all love Starbucks do
they yeah they're making so much money
that they're giving them a [ __ ]
Ferrari on the side and tell him to keep
quiet yeah so I haven't said anything up
until now are the girls though do the
girls are they or do they look like
they've been indoctrinated as there is
knitting and is there bacon going on do
they look like their heads down yeah you
know a show
heads yeah that's exactly what it's like
well dude wearing bonnets and [ __ ] those
are Klan girls who are who are have low
self-esteem and they don't talk back and
probably all pretty young anything they
all present the three there's been three
pregnant okay then can I say this Chris
have you made any of the girls pregnant
Chris say no it's Chris yeah listen I'm
asking you honestly but please say no no
you're [ __ ] lying well did you make
any of these girls did you have sex with
you have sex with the racist racist
babies dude you've known for way longer
than a day profits he made off his what
a [ __ ] thing this guy's doing he's
got a [ __ ] racist are buy so
disappointed impregnating young quiet
girls and bonnets I don't know man
you're a friend and [ __ ] but like like
you gotta [ __ ] you got there against
condoms better without so they're like
we're making up our own rules
I've gotta make this right jack dude you
gather yeah I will
your characters we I'm gonna make it
right today what are you gonna do what
do you do I swear to God what I'm gonna
march right down there yeah and I'm
gonna go home and I'm gonna [ __ ] I
know I'm gonna I'm gonna after I get a
coffee like [ __ ] sick I'm gonna say
he's gonna get a coffee
you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna open up
a rival [ __ ] coffee for blacks know
about that black well know
actually not a bad idea agent it has to
be colorblind that's the whole point of
this guy gotta have everybody in there
and then and you have to you're not
gonna drive them out of business you
have to just I'll Drive them out a bit
no you have to drive them out of
business first with the black coffee
being then the black coffee office
Seiken or everybody know you have to
just say this is illegal and you have to
just shut again trying to figure out a
way to [ __ ] deal with no Brian you
can't just go oh sorry oops fourteen
months he has to proactively get out
badly and start a black listen to me
listen to me I know how to solve this
problem that I would is I'll get some
masago white and they got their little
trust when they go in there they're
fighters yeah and we'll go in there I'm
gonna come with them and we're gonna
have pieces of hickory okay and we're
gonna wear these random pieces of here
we're gonna wear them in our pants and
then we're gonna come in and you have
one of those you know how we're gonna
get door they know you're threatening
how they get come in it's white white
yeah and then hey guys what can I get
you and then I'm gonna have a [ __ ]
you got one of those doors you have one
of those doors there's big industrial
doors because it's a Starbucks yes I'm
gonna come to one of those big padlocks
that you see on ships with the chains
yeah I'm gonna shine just real like have
locks that you'd use to keep to keep
gold in a large chest yeah and I'm gonna
go I'm gonna pull it I'm gonna pull
chain I'm gonna lock the door and I'm
gonna go there now you just can't leave
that's from Bronx Tale go on now you
can't that's the most famous line shut
the funny you'll be in the corner crying
like the [ __ ] Carroll bring me with
your the race race apologist racist upon
our hickory and and have a good old time
on some racist noggins
yeah and that's how we're gonna close
your [ __ ] Starbucks down and there it
was
I never saw Sonny so mad he beat up all
those guys at Starbucks and they all
would regretted the day day crossed him
when he locked the door and said that
and closer and closer
upon my face as I'm done as I'm done
making mincemeat literally of all
they're all that everybody in that
Starbucks was my chicory and I just come
up in there's blood that just it just
drips mmm no smoke the whole time and
that music for my funeral is playing and
then I kill myself
what yeah Wow weird weird I know wait
with my own head well yeah with my guys
hey so that was the longest bit we've
ever done a long bit yeah